Deadpool 2 has a new trailer and oh my
god were not ready for this
Chrissy Teigan is trolling her fans
again plus her money breaks her silence
on the fifth harmony shocker and the
dudes from workaholics are back and
dropping trou in their new movie hey
guys this is the daily Deni
I am Deni director legend at least I
wish I was before we get into that
Deadpool 2 trailer can we just recognize
today's Twitter MVP Chrissy Teigen who
really is the Twitter MVP of all time
let's be real but it all started when an
old tweet resurfaced about marriage
namely someone wanted to understand why
some women won't take their husband's
last name when they get married
Chrissy's response my husband didn't
even take his last name
Touche Chris because John Legend is not
John Legend his actual name is John
Roger Stevens but you know even that
sound argument wasn't enough of an
explanation for some when pressed again
Chrissy tweeted you'll never understand
the simple reason of because I don't
want to listen Chrissy is basically an
encyclopedia of sassy comebacks a to be
fair she is a legend you feel me on that
all right speaking of legendary a new
trailer for Deadpool 2 just dropped and
it is everything and it has everything
Josh Brolin has bad guy cable we also
get introduced to x-force in case you
were worried that the sequel could never
be as much twisted fun as the original
this should put you at ease
amen cable killed his kid
but I can't do this alone we're gonna
form a super duper needham topic morally
flexible and young enough to carry their
own franchise for 10 to 12 years x-force
you're absolutely right you're the right
thing is messy you want to fight for
what's right and fight dirty
that is why Sisterhood of the Traveling
Pants is pure pornography oh god I wish
I finished college I mean come on we
know Ryan Reynolds is gonna slay but the
wonder watching the sequel is easy beats
as domino here's what she told our ash
Crossin about going head-to-head with
Ryan
what can you tell me about you know
Domino and Deadpool's dynamic yeah well
I think Domino kind of meets that bull
head-to-head and doesn't really take
just fit him she's strong and she's
sarcastic and sardonic and I think
darkly funny in the way that Deadpool is
well we'll find out when Deadpool 2 hits
theaters May 18th by the way Deadpool
house exports now put the Internet at
one point through DP in the Hat to
replace Camila Kibeho in 5h
unfortunately for Deadpool fifth harmony
is not a thing right now and for all you
Harmonizers only et gotten our money
Corday breaking her silence on the
group's indefinite hiatus just a message
to the fans who are heartbroken oh I
love you guys so much and you make it
the best time in my life I'll never
forget it they'll be back right right
that is all right okay well while the
future of fifth harmony hangs in the
balance the dudes from workaholics are
still at it
Anders Holm Adam Devine and Blake
Anderson are together again for a new
movie but as I found out don't call it a
comeback it was like it's your reunion
toward you guys get that vibe yeah we
see each other quite a bit so it doesn't
feel like a reunion tour for us right
but I'm glad it is for the world where's
my belly hanging out
you seen a little here it is this time
the guys are teaming up for their new
Netflix action comedy game over man you
want for this we take their guns and
free the hostages we wanted to make
something that was gonna be much bigger
than workaholics and something that
people are gonna walk away and be like
oh my god want to turn it up you know
workaholics was seven years of fury yeah
and I think every one of our favorite
episodes were was like there's a little
action to it
Thanks were high and we were like let's
let's take that to the movie level took
it up a notch let me say the next level
well not only did the guys up the action
they up the nudity to that I wasn't
expecting as much blood and like male
anatomy in this did the fact that you
guys some other people said that I'm
like that's exactly what you think we're
big fans of like Tarantino so our first
movie out we're like we've got to make
our version of an 80s 90s fun big
actually but with more male anatomy
game over man hits Netflix March 23rd
but can we expect workaholics to make a
TV comeback I've been saying like we
have a spirit amongst like what we
always do like there's this there's a
shared thing there that we had before
workaholics with workaholics and we I
think have it in this movie absolutely
and we're just gonna continue to have it
whether or not it's a workaholic and who
knows we I want to do it when we're old
I want Blake Smith oh oh I I want ders
to shrink like four inches and I'm gonna
be 350 pounds and that's what I want to
take back on the roof you know those
guys are a blast and make sure you check
out game over man it is absolutely nuts
literally all right make sure you guys
come back tomorrow for new music Friday
plus for funsies I'm breaking down
Beyonce's most unforgettable tour
moments shocking I know I'll see you
guys there
[Music]